c'est une époque d'innovation et de
progrès les plus grands esprits de ce
monde repousse les frontières du
possible jusqu'à explorer l'inconcevable
mon ami victor frankenstein est l'un de
ces hommes
je rêve d'un monde où l'espoir en place
la barre ou un handicapé ne guérit
remarcher et si nous pouvions donner à
chaque fille la chance qu'elle mérite
igor aide moi à changer le monde
une différence entre utiliser une
machine pour restaurer une vie et crée
une chose qui n'aurait jamais dû exister
j'ai réussi
il est vivant
je trouve vos travaux stupéfiants vous
pourriez en crée un autre je pourrais
faire beaucoup plus
prenez garde monsieur frankenstein la
vie est une création sacré je rêve d'une
armée d'un million d'immortels à ma
disposition
hector vous m'aviez promis que votre but
c'était la vie c'est désormais tellement
plus
meurtrier
pour ça
une